in the movie Elvis is in the midst of
filming a television comeback special
when Robert Kennedy's assassination
occurs in June 1968. Colonel Tom Parker
has explicitly sold the show to NBC as a
Christmas special to be aired in
December however Elvis wants to use the
special to get back to his rock and roll
roots and chart a new way forward in his
career against the Colonel's wishes he
ditches the Christmas sweaters for a
black leather jumpsuit the resulting
concert film commonly known as the 68
Comeback Special is a Smash Hit and
Latter-Day Triumph for the king it's
been a big change in the music fee in
the last 10 or 12 years however Presley
and Parker's Clash is largely invented
for the film in real life the special
was never meant to be a Christmas
special other than by virtue of airing
in December biographer Elena Nash told
variety there was never a Christmas
sweater or fairy tale Christmas set
that's Lerman being the Showman